[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
true
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
am i we'll find out welcome back to the
break room
all you breakers all your roomies all
your trashy super trash out there pick a
nickname uh we're testing out a lot of
nicknames trashies yeah was rumors one
of them roomies roomies and breakers
breakers yeah they love it they love it
all and we love you and welcome back to
the bread room this is our daily live
show that covers all the nerd news that
you need to know and maybe some nerd
news you didn't even need to know it's a
monday we're so happy to be back uh
we're so glad you're all here coming up
on the show today we have new news
or some news on stranger things it's new
news to me it's an always new
all news is new at some point well it's
old news and you don't want to be that
you don't want to be old news uh we're
also going to talk to doctor strange too
no
she's old news
old news and we're also going to talk
about miss marvel and we're going to be
doing tons of future casting on the
episode today so put your little theory
hats on and make sure they fit snuggly
and that they're appropriate to wear
endorse i'm joined today by a lovely
panel of people i'm of course brandon
that's not important but joining us
today is phil bellina
you kind of mispronounced my name i did
a little bit okay it's okay i don't i
don't care it's spelled stupid too
and then we also have jessica clemens on
the show today
and tommy
hi everyone it's so great to be here
today we've turned over a new leaf
positive monday last week didn't happen
and i just want to say all of last week
last friday that never happened i just
want to say each and every one of you is
wonderful and we're so grateful to have
you here thanks for sticking along guys
that was a kind thing to say it sounds
like somebody is going to get arrested
and like waiting for the sheriff's
office to show yeah yeah i think you may
have been listening to your programmed
over the weekend can we show everyone
some pictures of me as a child
exactly remember all the good i've done
from a mourinho stop trying to humanize
tommy uh
we of course uh on the show today we
have our reverse swear jar going for our
chat redemptions what is the reverse
sweatshirt hold on pause you know who
you're gonna explain this to you can
explain to t ray plays who thinks this
is pre-recorded ah there's always some
punks in the chat that say oh it's
pre-recorded because they want us to say
their name guys now you said that no i
think it's actually because our frame
rate is should be 30 frames per second
but anyway
hey guys can i point out something
maybe t-ray just needs a little
attention today
maybe t-ray just thought why don't i
type this thing that i know is clearly
false in hopes that my favorite four
people in the world will recognize my
existence and maybe for once
i'll feel like i'm worth something and
to which i say
you are worth it t-ray
i like the idea that his name's just
trae
he's like hey he just commented okay
it's not
got him got him what is the reverse
swear jar you keep demanding me to
explain it uh we're not allowed to curse
on this show uh it's it's not permitted
by the government or whoever runs the
internet uh but if we raise a hundred
dollars in super chats we'll crack the
square jar and let a little swear gin
fly out and and grant swear wishes to
each of us uh what happens if we pass
the 200 mark i don't know
crack that 100 and you'll find out uh
but like i said before we got tons to
talk about on the show but the most
important thing we have to talk about
are the headlines
headlines headlines first headline in an
interview with variety millie bobby
brown weighed in on whether or not she
thinks 11 created the upside down uh she
said quote this is too big of a debate
for me to answer
end quote
leave me leave me now please please exit
my dormitory
she followed up with i'm so worried i
think no no no i think that the
alternate universe was always there that
is always going to be under hawkins i
just think she has access to it i don't
think that she created the upside down
which is exactly what eleven would say
okay
i don't i don't want we're in a good
mood so like let's not dwell on this
but
it would be really badass if it was
actually like a metaphor for like
childhood trauma and like the safe space
that you create for yourself
and like you know it looks it looks like
your world but it's kind of like the
dark side of it or whatever oh it would
be cool it would be cool just saying it
i mean she clearly created it and she's
covering it up
why are you lying i also i read that
entire interview which was pretty
interesting
and like the question before she's kind
of like yeah no 11 created the upside
down and then she like
backtracks it for that quote so i don't
know i i think that there's certainly a
lot left to be seen and i encourage
everyone to stick along what a great
time for media i'm just so glad that all
my friends are here is this is this like
the uh buffy the vampire slayer where
the town is on top of a hell mouth oh or
is it like the buffy the vampire slayer
episode where it turns out she actually
just might be crazy and we just don't
know it could all be in her head oh wow
i mean they're gaslighting her sister
was uh wasn't there before and all of a
sudden she's there we can talk buffy all
day
yeah tommy didn't used to exist
and none well that's true none of you
existed prior to 1983 yeah i didn't
exist at all and then the hell mouth
opened and everything yeah crawling well
grown baby
please do not speak of my mother's
reproductive system
hey i just said it was a hellmouth you
said it was your mother's reproductive
system i i pictured a hole in the ground
that you came out of again please don't
refer to
no picture
i like it
okay next headline uh we also got our
new deleted scene from doctor strange
too where he was in the multiverse of
madness uh it's a flashback of dr
strange and christine being interviewed
for a documentary i'll uh like
office yeah or almost exactly
yeah the scene has really big jim and
pam office 5. we were just talking about
this we think it was maybe a joke yeah i
mean it's they're speaking i don't know
if you guys uh out there or if you guys
here watch this clip it is set in front
of some uh horizontal blinds
kind of the way the office always was
like where they were like interviewing
them in the break room or the car
becomes remember like their their their
talking heads were and they're just kind
of like flirting with each other
about like work like it's all about like
who like oh you got credit for this
procedure and he's complimenting her but
he's also dr strange so he's still kind
of thinking it's very jim and pam do you
think this was gonna be a sequence where
they're going through multiverses and
this is the universe that is the office
that to me was maybe there was a conan
emmy's intro from 2007 where he did that
oh yeah and he went through like he goes
through lost and 24 in the office and he
calls out those two uh brandon uh you
just gave me a deal tommy uh this is
breaking brandon can you step aside with
me real quick yeah sure uh and just if
you can cut the camera one
great all right uh so this is an episode
of the office uh or an interview session
oh okay go for it
we got to interview us
there's always an implied question right
like how do you think things are going i
think they're going into camera don't
look at us
they're going great everything at the
break room has never been better i don't
think i've ever been more overjoyed to
be with tommy than today
i feel very nervous that that's not true
jessica and i are going on a vacation to
austin to do a show for for new rock
stars and it's going to be awkward i
don't know what's going to happen why is
it going to be awkward well because you
know when we're in a foreign place we
just can't help ourselves
we've got to cut there
established that austin was a foreign
place yeah austin's actually 838. hey
keep it weird i love how quickly the
rhythm changes to that like ricky
gervais yeah you're like slowly
inspector knight just called us the
break room casting couch and i hate it
absolutely not uh new headline james
gunn and frequent collaborator
vfx supervisor betsy patterson recently
sat down to chat on deadlines video
series the process among the things they
talked about was their work on the
upcoming guardians of the galaxy
christmas special which gunn described
as quote light bubbly and fun and
absolutely ridiculous end quote
uh we're super excited for the special
what does this mean
for the special i think it just means if
you're looking for
like the canon lore of guardians of the
galaxy to be extended by some like
breakthrough things maybe set your
expectations to more like isn't this fun
that we have
bonafide
mcu stars doing a christmas special for
tv or streaming rather this is really
neat and i think it's cool that they're
doing it they do this for more
properties that disney owns from then i
hope dc does them slightly less is good
uh
do you guys have a favorite our favorite
christmas specials
well i mean the charlie brown christmas
special but that's only the star wars
one
you like the star wars holiday special
completely there's a really good uh
video on this channel called bootleg
breakdown star wars christmas special
that i urge you all to check out we'll
link it in the comments i'm sure we
won't uh it's been buried in the
algorithm
uh mine's a real video though my
favorite it is a real video and i worked
really hard on it it's uh my favorite
christmas special one of them for sure
pee wee's playhouse pee-wee's christmas
special with just a million late 80s
early 90s stars magic johnson dynashore
charo
i forget who else magic johnson and
magic screen are cousins in that because
but that was like the child like logic
of that show i always like christmas
specials that end with like wait i'm
picking something up
like reindeer bells yeah i need to do
that
yeah so many of them like establish
santa claus as being real
which would make sense and like in the
mcu it would be very funny if there's
like there's an eternal out there oh
there's gotta be a real santa santa
there's a real jesus and a real santa
claus and they're out there in the mcu
yeah we've gotta find that i love the
billion people that just got offended
that you said there's a real jesus out
there
a billion that's generous hey new
headline
we've got new thor loving thunder images
from total film let's pop them up on the
screen
whoa
oh bro the muscles are getting bigger
there is bigger than his head i know i
mean that's a good angle
why is he dressed up like big trouble
little china i mean i think they're
going for that
he's
i think we got a couple others uh yeah
oh look at that her arm is bigger than
her head i know looking looking strong
looking like she's in wherever that
meeting between the world leaders is
happening that valkyrie's at in the
trailer you get your looks like camille
gets here yeah uh and then finally uh
meditative thor uh
what do you call those like um those
people that you go to seek wisdom from a
guru a guru is a type but i think he's
playing the love guru yes i think he's
playing specifically mike myers is the
love girl oh yeah i think it's i think
most of thor love and thunder is just
gonna be a retread um
i hope so including justin timberlake um
guys that picture that moment where you
see thor naked uh in in the trailer uh
that it isn't insane how much bigger he
is still getting like crimson
it's like the hulk when he gets angrier
like he might not have a limit yeah it
reminds me of uh you know hugh jackman's
progression yeah
crazy really
even more and more ripped we saw this
with chris evans i feel like every time
he had to be captain america he got a
little bit bigger but hemsworth is
really doing it i think it's a
combination of like they know how to do
it their body's been primed for it and
also like every year the science gets a
little better sure sure they're probably
like sleeping in oxygen tanks and taking
some sort of injections i don't know
what they are i like are you so close
honestly
the ac is blasting and i've been like
getting out of there
i think it's cute i like it i personally
think camera 2 is probably really a
treat right now
it's a real treat
yeah i am jealous uh i just i'm very i'm
hopeful by the results of this poll are
you planning to watch the guardians of
the galaxy christmas special almost 90
yes which i mean obviously we are but
that seems exciting good yeah yeah i
think you're more excited ten percent
said no
yeah but i mean they hate christmas yeah
but you know what real quick sorry
camera four
maybe that ten percent just
needed a shout out needed people to
recognize them today that christmas
isn't the best time for them
and that
you know maybe if we recognize them and
let them know that guardians of the
galaxy holiday special or christmas
special is it the holiday special it's
the holidays it's the holidays you
should stop going at a christmas special
i'll tell you what they better not have
red and green cuts on set uh
you know what if you're not excited to
watch it give it a try anyway and come
talk about it with us in the break room
because we love you guys and it's a gift
to get to be around each other right
yeah give me camera one real quick um
painter yes grosgu is on my shirt
um this is groku and this is grogo oh
basketball team the only basketball team
i recognize
a space jam jersey is the only athletic
jersey i've ever heard yeah
i thought that's where sports began
really quick my brother was trying to
make me cold one year like going into
middle school and he took me to sports
authority and he's like you can pick out
any jersey and i bought the bugs bunnies
no
you're poor you weren't cool you were
cool you're a poor bro
baby oh you could have even you could
have gotten a debt left shrimp jersey
and been better than that don't even
know what that is yeah that's right and
that's why
beautiful stuff uh we also ran a poll
asking if you think 11 made the upside
down uh 69 percent nice said no
why why can't eleven make the upside
down she's the problem
we gotta stop her she's gotta be stopped
you gotta be stopped i know i'm a
villain
villain confirmed uh and don't forget
about the super chat sentiment if you
got questions uh uh michael galliego
saying i love you guys we love you too
michael uh and if we hit that hundred
dollar mark we'll curse about it
wouldn't that be fun don't you guys want
me to curse yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna
institute a new rule because i haven't
really been here for any of these
cursing right right right
if they hit the hundred dollar mark
they're gonna curse but they're not
gonna use any curse word they've used on
this show before oh my god
from like elf so
there's a
unrated version
yeah
he
[Music]
who is this girl
what am i going to say to her is this
khan are you in james cotton
i'm going to kill her
right outside gimbal's department store
don't talk to myself don't judge me
that's the most
don't talk to me don't talk to my phone
speaking of the godfather we know some
mcu fans are starting to get a little
nervous starting to wonder about the
current direction of the films and where
all these movies and tv shows are
heading but our very own godfather of
the mcu kevin feige he's not going to
leave us hanging
as part of that total film story that
had those new images from thor 11
thunder uh feige revealed that answers
are coming sooner rather than later as
to what the next big saga is in the mcu
he also kind of teased that like oh it's
you know the clues are there kind of
thing but it's like well that's easy for
you to say i've always been there yeah
you're getting all the emails right uh
but you know one thing we were talking
about around the office is like it seems
like kang
is the next big threat right he's maybe
the thanos level threat or is he yeah is
he secretly uh who's gonna help them
though well
i was
thinking about this
yesterday which is really funny that you
bring this up
i was thinking about this yesterday
because i don't want kane to end in
ant-man and wasp in quantomania but it
doesn't seem like he's going to be the
big bad overall because secret invasion
seems like it's going to be what we're
really headed towards does that make
sense yeah so i don't think he's going
to be the big thing in that but do you
think there could be like a domestic
we haven't had this much of a split
before in the mcu there could be like an
earthbound phase that we're dealing with
and then there's like cosmic ones and
then maybe they yeah and then maybe they
like intersect at some point okay i i
have a suspicion that it's going to be
god do like god leveled yeah
i think because that kind of transcends
both of those things but also
i think that we just
we kind of also have our main and our
protagonists have yet to fully be
revealed like we have our existing
players and we're meeting new characters
like ms marvel and moon knight that we
don't necessarily know how much they i
mean ms marvel will be in the marvels
but we don't know moon knight's next
step cinematically it feels like there's
going to be a floodgate of fantastic
four and doctor
fantastic fours is confirmed for phase
five right right yes they are making
them so you gotta have your dear dooms
well and like the phase thing i feel
like that's something that still yeah
media and fans are using because they
trained us that way right i couldn't
find it but i feel like i remember them
kind of saying like well we're not
really seeing it as phases anymore right
it's just like a constant stream
absolutely should because it makes it
easier like our question today the
inhumans and enhanced and superhuman
it's like you need to declare it we need
that but it's all blending too much now
i feel like the first phase one and two
were so easier to separate but these
ones are they're gonna start well they
were separated by the avengers movie
which we don't have on the set of
avengers as far as we've got attention
and we don't even have anything in the
lineup that's like this is the team-up
movie right yeah i was talking to
somebody earlier today and they're like
i was so caught up on on marvel and even
on the comics and then i got to end game
and it was so satisfying yeah that it
was hard to like stay as caught up after
that because it doesn't have that like
you know until i thought when i went to
go see far from home and it was over and
i was like oh that was a good movie but
like there was nothing that happened to
them right right you know there there's
a lot that happens also uh claire doom
isn't confirmed we just
how are you going to approach the
fantastic program i'm talking about yeah
if he's not in the
to be at the very edge fantastic four
kevin feistel how are you gonna approach
man somebody go talk to kevin
if they chose to do it
when they do fantastic four and if they
do not come to approach dr doom within
that first movie i'm going to be very
mad i know that we've already done it
before but it's like we can do it again
they could go they could go okay they
could
go like a silver surfboard route okay
instead and then like be headed toward
galactus and then dr doom is like a good
guy in the background and eventually
that's what i want i want that small
cameo of them working with doctor doom
before he's like yeah and he's like i
know my name is a little
scared
i mean my thing that i i'm kind of
leaning towards that got introduced the
concept got introduced in multiverse of
madness are the incursions and that's
like a big that those are the big level
events in the comics most recently is
like uh these incursions happening and i
think it's a great way to get the
mutants into the mcu where it's like all
the mutants come from a universe that's
dying and they're like almost like
refugees and they come streaming in but
this incursion creates like a ton of
other problems that have to be addressed
i also love the idea of uh reed
richard's kids uh wife and kids coming
to our universe to get revenge
i know we're kind of like taking it out
we're starting from the original
question straight
but do we do we want the um his children
to already be the children that we see
in the comics with their powers or do we
want them to start getting their powers
i don't know i want to see those kids
get made on film
hey
you know what man we got straight
straight from sue storm's hell mouth
like once it's the same thing as jim and
pam going back to the gym champion they
were more interesting before they had
kids that make sense so like let's get
some time with just them and then one
epic night
speaking of epic nights
i had an epic night last night oh yeah
yeah on the lord's night i was uh
feeling kind of frictiony feeling kind
of like my
my my man's sweater was rubbing up
against my real sweater i was in santa
monica where it gets a little chillier
i'm so confused here's where i need this
body hair our friends at manscape okay
[Laughter]
there's a certain confidence that comes
with being properly groomed camera three
head on over me meet my gaze
there's an aura a vive you can just tell
by the way they carry themselves we call
this bge big groomed energy there's only
one way to get that bge and that's
manscaped we'd like to introduce you to
the best and biggest ultimate hygiene
bundle yet the platinum package 4.0
manscaped is the leader in below the
waist grooming and by the way i go above
the waist with it okay
above and beyond the list i take that
manscaped wherever it needs to go to get
me from yeti too
already
i have that uh that exact thing i have
two of them one in my shower and one on
my sink uh because they're good for both
are they worried because by the time you
exit the shower and get to this i've
already regrown
the santa claus we actually are moving
away from talking a lot about the shower
stuff uh not for any specific reason but
uh as the person who does run our ad
copy i i don't care if we can scroll
back a little bit to that call to action
like
maybe just let me stick to this one join
the four million men worldwide who trust
manscape by going to the manscape.com
for 20 off plus free shipping with the
code break room now for years i've
walked the earth as part man part
something else swimming has been a
nightmare for me clogging drains causing
pains everyday tasks such as getting
groceries and feeding on the souls of
the damned we're a nightmare for me that
is until i started my grooming routine
with manscaped manscape's brand new
platinum 4.0 is the biggest bundle
they've ever offered giving you a bulk
discount of manscape's top products the
manscape platinum package 4.0 is the
one-stop shop for the men who deserve it
all okay they designed this package to
allow you to fully align your hygiene
routine with elite products inside the
platinum package you'll find their
lawnmower for lawn mower 4.0 weed
whacker ear and nose hair trimmer which
god knows i need one of those i need
this new package ultra premium body wash
ultra premium two in one shampoo and
conditioner ultra premium deodorant crop
preserver anti-shaving ball deodorant
crop reviver ball spray toner
anti-chafing boxers and the shed travel
bag to hold your goods while traveling
heavens to betsy okay now listen we're a
manscaped crew here we all thought over
who got to do this ad you can see even
now we're all trying to get in on it
because we all love our manscape
products and that's not just the men on
this show we got a ladyscaper here
she might chime in later in the week we
don't know we're going to talk to her
about that see if it's in her contract
get 20 off free shipping with the code
breakthrough at manscape.com that's 20
off with free shipping at manscape.com
user code break room unlock your big
groomed energy with manscape and
remember when you trim the hedges the
tree strands wait
hold on cut your edit give it to me on
four
when you trim the hedges
your dick strands taller
really really leaned into the oh man hey
if you liked that metaphor go ahead and
smash that like button yeah that would
be really helpful i love one of you so
much i love when you write your own copy
and just go to land
you love that because for me it was it
hurt my feelings
well you know i might feel like when you
made it feel weird that i showered no
all right i'll tell you we also want to
let you all know that new rock stars is
going to be appearing live in austin
texas as part of the rtx austin 2022
podcast festival shopping july 1st
through july 3rd uh if you've ever
wanted to see some of your favorite new
rock stars post in person you don't have
to say who your favorites are but
philip's gonna be there no jessica's
gonna be there
tommy's gonna be there i'll be there
it's gonna be your channel they'll be in
other people
to possibly drink with us in person whoa
and when i say that i only say there's
only a few bars and i'm going to one of
them
although jessica also told us that she
didn't want to hang out with me
which i felt it was like a direct threat
to me she was like don't think we're
hanging out all weekend
she has plans and she's got plans she's
got to read i just want to sit poolside
and work on my tag i really like that
it was like within moments of finding
that we were going to austin tommy
already invited us to a party his
uncle's having yes in austin yes right
away yes they're gonna keep it weird in
austin there's gonna be a thing that
very few people have ever seen we did a
show in chicago it's a thing you've
never seen on the channel it's a special
kind of game show entertainment kind of
thing it may or may not feature an
aerial boss and uh they might not don't
don't turn them away
and we
are going to do it again kind of a even
more intense version in austin so if you
want to see more things that we don't do
on the channel lives will be on the line
people's jobs will be on the line the
best part is it involves you guys in the
audience yeah along with us we represent
certain members in the audience and i'll
say it in chicago i was the one that won
so yeah my person got the number you're
dominant also my person got me drunk
my person gave me my first shot of my
lord uh yeah oh
and i do and and we do we are looking
forward to meeting and talking to you
guys some of us others will run away and
and again please behave yourselves
because we're going to bring eric but
we're not going to unleash him unless
you're voting all right
another quick real quick embarrassing
story here uh uh i got drunk there for
the first time a long time because i
normally have a gallon of water every
day and i didn't that day and i'd been
pulled an all-nighter and so i was drunk
for the first time a long time and i
tried to kiss someone who i should not
have tried to kiss and it haunts me to
this day it was me
there it is and by the way
you're judging yourself because i would
have i would have done it again you
pulled away quicker than i would like
famous chicago resident former president
united states michael jordan yeah yeah
rahm emanuel uh blocked me
he'll dive right in there but yeah if
you want to go to rtx austin 2022
podcast festival it's a it's a lengthy
name click on that link we got in the
description use promo code new rockstars
all one word and you could save a little
money on your on your ticket everybody
else is going to be amazing yeah be all
of other panels there it's a three-day
event there's tons of stuff going on
they're much fun we're on saturday you
guys it's rooster teeth you'll see elise
williams that's enough so muslim is
amazing oh yeah amazing absolutely so
does their ticket get them into the
whole thing they have different tickets
available you can buy just for the day
we have it you could buy a three-day
pass you got vip packages all sorts of
stuff but save a little dough uh and use
the new rockstars discount code and if
your van mow me don't already don't if
you're an edmond
i was not going to say where the hair
comes from but i like it thanks to man
let's just say we're making the tree
stand taller yeah speaking of trees
stand taller it's time to hand out some
diplomas with mandatory fun oh
diploma mandatory
they did roll the graphic the segment's
so nice we're only going to roll the
graphic once because we're short-handed
today and i'm done being an emotional
terrorist with this segment now i don't
believe that for a second no guys it's a
new me it's a new day i'm feeling good
now chris evans said an interview with
mtv news recently that he would love to
come back to the mcu as johnny storm in
the fantastic four now this is very
different than the quote he gave earlier
where he was like i don't it'd be so
hard for me to come back as captain
america
only there's enough money in the world
for people
i'm just kidding he has a ton of
integrity he loves dogs he's so good
that he's gotta be bad he's gotta be bad
mocking him is fun because you know it's
like mocking tom hanks who will only
swear at you when you try and run his
wife
okay have you guys seen the puppy
interview yeah okay it's amazing chris
evans not good enough right he has to be
amazing he especially he's requested
that they also add uh elderly dogs too
to the
like
i heard there was originally like ten of
the same puppy they kept eating them
yeah and that's why they only show one
but it's different i think for buzzfeed
and said that he kicked four of them
yeah and the elderly dogs it was to put
them down why did you want to see me
throw one of these like a shield and he
did it yeah
my friend owns buzzfeed and they said he
demanded to coat his entire lower half
in peanut butter and then he said i'm
doing the whole interview with no pants
release the puppy
first he goes first these puppies are
gonna dine
and then i'm gonna feel fine
anyway i gotta get my supplies for
mandatory while you do that
all right now
more chris evans lander
we are proud to invite you for this
segment of mandatory fun to the mcu yes
that's right the marvel cinematic
university
because we've received some applicants
to join the mcu our first applicant
is chris evans who would like to come
back as johnny storm now earlier via our
work slack we took a vote as to whether
or not we thought chris evans should
join you were tagged on this i don't
know if you've i have not opened select
in like a week oh that's cool uh good to
know that the tags work no wonder i
haven't gotten my uh deeply needed
health insurance cleared by our boss uh
bill phillip claire's everything yeah
yeah to be fair it's a really weird
system we have no i just in general
getting health insurance i'm not getting
anything cleared i just need someone to
sign off saying i have it anyway
we've uh chris was a unanimous a
unanimous three to zero vote to be
welcomed back as johnny storm we're
gonna write his acceptance letter now uh
if you guys can just help me out with it
uh sure let's say we go dear
should we call him dear johnny
yeah we referencing he's coming back as
johnny's
giant storm from the multiverse
so we're working we're emailing this to
him well i don't know if we can email
because i'm handwriting it but we are
going to put it in the middle but you
say don't flame on because this is on
paper yeah yeah don't flame on and i'm
going to add a ha ha ha yeah yeah
because but he's going to be really
excited and he might accidentally flame
on yeah
okay uh
this dear john letter is a good thing
oh was he into your jar well no
are you familiar with the concept of a
dear john letter oh if he's interested
in women that are five foot seven
do you
like is that too tall
five i'm so sorry seven
okay
i'm filming but i might be johnny
uh okay let's let's give let's let's
give one more
wait or men or men
please question mark and then can you
add please bring your sister please
chris evans assistant
i've never met chris evans sister susan
someone asked can you also come back as
cap can you ask them that also you're
accepted into the mcu yes we accept yes
yeah also you get to swear yeah you did
win the swear we did break the square
jar okay
i can barely let's get this ready
before okay i will not use the uh i
swear second up is miles teller who has
also
despite being in the josh strength
fantastic four generally maligned by
fans and critics alike has expressed the
desire to come back as reed richards now
here's what was confusing uh about this
one
miles teller received a vote of no
a vote of yes
and a vote of a little bit interested so
here's what i've decided to do as the
head dean
of the uh marvel cinematic university
i've decided miles teller will be put on
a uh wait list we're gonna wait against
them we're gonna wait less okay so let's
figure out i get to swear so i'm going
to i'm going to start this off
dear curse words you haven't used on the
show before yes thank you
dear
charlatan
oh whoa in a different
[Music]
your arrogance
has betrayed you oh
oh my goodness you should just write
this this is just for the wait list
imagine you got rejected okay yeah you
are wait listed yeah
call him a slag
yeah calm with slack yeah call me a swag
too
stop stop
yeah there it is
next time get on our tempo yeah oh yeah
next time
get on our tempo
oh and what does he have to do to get
off the waitlist i think you spelled
tempo wrong t-e-m-p-o
[Music]
uh and keep it above the hard deck
do you like women who are five seven
yeah i'm not interested no i don't wanna
you like women who are five seven we
need options i don't want him i mean
charlie 836 did ask i'm just going to
ask you like
do you like men i don't like i like that
one just do you like that question i
agree with circle history cj in the chat
that miles teller is amazing just not as
read he's not my read and that's why i
was too young to be around i was the
person that voted this because i was
like i won't mind him coming back in
fantastic four period as long as it's
not reading he's got to wait 15 years
can somebody remind me why we we stopped
liking miles teller for a little while
oh he gave some interviews that were
kind of like an esquire right he was
yeah he's a cool person
well he did he did the thing that a lot
of i think actors in there he did
linda
there's a long line of actors that are
slapping
so no i think what his cardinal sin was
other than you know some questionable
political beliefs for the mainstream for
the woke mainstream uh
i think he yeah he gave that interview
where it was like you know the typical
male lead movie star
i'm not even really interested in acting
in films that people watch i just kind
of want to roll around in dirt and just
kind of make my own heart and then he
said something similar to that about
fantastic four he was like i don't
understand why people didn't like it as
much it was just really fun and i was
like well it's because of what the
fantastic four means but now he's
weightless
and i'm remembering the writer of the
article was like roasting him she was
like
yeah was like he's walking in and he's
doing that thing where he's pretending
to be real cool by not seeing me or
something yeah thanks uh dawson in the
chat for a poll of do you like men yes
sir
ah yes good let's get to the answer of
this uh okay so we have to get through
these because we still have ten more
notice yeah two more uh this one's
really quick jennifer garner no
no no
she got a straight three knows the
answer is just no jennifer garner and
thirteen going on thirty
i want the 13 going on 30 character to
become
mine electric coming
or sydney bristow i don't mind jennifer
garner coming back in general yeah maybe
not as electro i i think so i think
that's fair now here's here's the last
one and it's tricky but you have to just
keep an open mind okay
david hasselhoff has applied to come
back as nick fury
he is the original nick fury director of
shield from the 1998 sci-fi original
movie
nick fury could come or david assaf
could come back as nick fury but only
only as a variant obviously of course
obviously we're not replacing samuel l
with hasselhoff anytime soon
but uh i think it's
i think we should give him a chance i
think he comes back as a villain version
of yeah
like i'm from a timeline where i took
over yes and i i i stormed the capitol
on january 6th yeah and i took down the
government and now i'm in charge i'm
nick fury 150. can i get a shot of this
uh no one can see look at that yeah they
can look that is the version of this is
david hasselhoff in 2022. this is right
now and he sounds he looks exactly how
brandon just sounded he's become old man
fury like cause it's
like fury has some sort of uh he was
given like uh not the super soldiers
here but he was given some sort of juice
yes at some point that makes him live
longer
clear pepsi yeah yeah he drank too much
crystal pepsi that's why they took it
off the market it was too powerful now
okay so here's what i'm hearing
he can come back if he's bad we're gonna
let him back in he's got the look as a
variant as kind of an evil
version of nick fury we're gonna let him
back in he looks good he also has a
connection remember he did that fun
remix of uh song for guardians of the
galaxy right uh volume two no you know
germany
centric song you did like the credit
song that was like a 70s sci-fi style
disco song
okay so he'll be a variant right yes and
i think maybe it all works as he has er
miles hillary needs to get off the
waitlist always seems to happen so that
there's another mcu that's out there
that is more about the fantastic four it
weirdly has chris evans as johnny
we don't want to mix up the black
panther villainy you know in there yeah
so there's a weird combo one there and
that their nick fury is david hasselhoff
and he's evil pamela anderson is sue
storm why not baywatch cast this whole
thing that would be amazing
david chocochi is johnny storm
apocalypse wow i completely agree with
that would love to see that also
that suits storm would take zero like
that's your storm would be like see this
yeah
emily anderson you can see on broadway
right now in chicago
chicago her broadway debut good for her
good hey his discount code rockstar new
rockstars
office try new rock stories see what
happens pam you and i have come a long
way together famous videos you've done
it together emphasis on [ __ ] anyway oh my
gosh
is that out you've used before on the
show
probably is it a curse word or is it
something beautiful
as tommy was handing me
every letter just mail off i'm going to
mail off a hat
a fortune teller perfect a circle
um that finger
and
this frog that fell apart all right this
has been mandatory fun thank you so much
for joining us class dismissed
thank you
hey this says that we're going to be
talking about iman valani next i wonder
who's going to do it
jessica is there it is for our second
discussion part you guys in a recent
interview aman valani said she didn't
expect to be the main character in the
marvels the marvel is set to come out
next year in july
as of right now it might get pushed like
everything else does you know you know
how they do um is set to come out next
year july and focuses on carol danvers
kamala khan
and monica rambo uh sam jackson should
also be featured as nick fury
she her saying that she didn't expect to
be
the main character of the marvels might
come as sort of surprise to some of you
guys you're probably like oh why would
she be the main character
we need to remember that this is now
uh the person who she admires captain
america or captain america she also
marries captain america yeah but her
number one is carol danvers as captain
marvel and she's in space somewhere
while monica could be on earth trying to
help her but there's that animosity that
monica has towards carol danvers because
we don't know yet yeah she had a very
charged line about her yeah
his energy yeah yeah very x energy i was
i still ride for the fact that i think
um
that carol danvers
inexplicably might have killed her mom
like she had her energy i think they
were doing too much stuff because
they're also still she was like an
engineer that could also go to space so
why wouldn't they work together a little
bit a lot of stuff and maybe she got
exposed to something not a terrible well
being outside of the ozone layer you
immediately are exposed to way more
radiation
i think that's i think this is a good
time to also explore it and talk about
it um but
so do you guys think
do you guys believe what i'm saying
where it could be a team-up version of
like
carol danvers and monica having to train
kamala khan and this stuff is just
happening way too fast i i i would think
that if i hadn't played the avengers
game where she's like the lead of it and
it actually is almost inverted right
where it's like she needs that training
instead she's their only hope
yeah because that's also a world where
like the avengers are disbanded and like
there's no we're kind of in that world
now right yeah like
they're off world and who knows who's
they even joke about that right like is
there an avengers right now
who's on it who's running it that's true
oh my gosh i didn't even know so they
need they need come on con yes
and so the the way that uh the marvel's
ends is with essentially our new
official avengers
i can see that happening
we do still have monica and carol hating
each other or at least monica hating
carol so she could be the one to bring
them back together because they're all
using similar powers and so it's like we
need to work together girls come on
ladies come on and she's just like no
but i no matter what i stand with what
monica's mad about right now we need the
mad men elevator meme of uh uh where
monica is talking to carol and she's
like i hate you i hate everything you
stand for and carol's like i don't even
know who you are yeah you're combining
the thanos what me oh yeah i'm combining
something don't think about it an actual
mcu reference yesterday yes
that line in mad men if you have not
watched mad men yet is the most
cold-blooded delivery
what's that
yeah it's the line
yeah no i'm saying it's
i i got distracted i thought you guys
were disagreeing or oh no i don't know
it is one of the most savage deliveries
of the line of all time because the guy
is yeah exactly he's like the guy who's
like
trying to chide don draper of like
you're pathetic i pity i think he says i
feel sorry for you and then he goes
nothing about you i don't think
about you
is jon hamm not in the mcu in any way
no he was potentially mr sinister yeah
catch to play mr sinister that's part of
like the x-men
ham dude
four letters four letters
if i could get him we'd be on a date
first
john hamm do you like women who are five
cents or men i know he doesn't answer
the problem no you do uh do you think
well we can write them yeah john john
jonathan
security number so you know
so he knows all right just for saying
out loud for everybody um three three
okay
[Laughter]
i didn't have a good point though
jessica about jon hamm no uh
it does seem like there's a long way to
go from
where we are now in miss marvel to a
film involving
carol danvers and monica rambo and
uh kamala khan as like a lead character
yes because both both captain marvel and
photon or specter or whatever she's
gonna call herself uh are very op
they're very overpowered yes carol
danvers has obviously shown that and
then in one division we saw how like
uh photon has a wide array of powers
including being able to be shot have the
bullets pass right through her without
even trying hey wait hold on i can be
shot and have bullets pass through well
and she's survived that's if we're
showing up she survives settle
so like what how do we think they're
gonna bridge the gap on the show because
apparently unless unless there's more
story for them in secret invasion or
something how do they get from where we
think they are now to the marvels i
think another question like why does
captain marvel or photo even care about
kamala khan well okay so i think a big
thing to
uh that i also have been questioning
kind of goes on top of your questions
how long has uh captain marvel been away
but also how long has she had her powers
because we saw her in the movie get in
like what the 90s the 90s the 90s well
she had it yes i don't know how long she
got in the 90s yeah and then she was
already what age when that happened so
i'm just saying i'm saying 20s or
something i'm saying this because if
it's been like what if she's like 68
years old she's much more mature she's
seen the entire world she's like i don't
have time for all of this but i think if
something big happens at the end of miss
marvel something huge not terrigen mism
huge but like something equal to that
that's when she's like i have to finally
get involved because this child started
something right and she's also wearing
my outfit and calling herself my name so
she's
that's why and i think she's racing
there when monica has already made it
there okay and then they both clash and
it's like i haven't seen you said you're
a child it's like i haven't seen you
since my mom died and you were gone
and i've never seen you
since you irradiated my mother's house
yes i haven't seen you so i think that
is the tipping stone to the marvels i
think it's kind of crazy to assume that
just because it's like right kevin feige
put all his eggs in miss marvel's show
like the basket and was just like
hopefully
yeah it works out i have an alt pitch
okay ult for how you get to the marvels
from miss marvel somewhere late in in
miss marvel we have kamala uh
needy it's so the issue becomes so big
that she's like we need captain marvel
we need a real hero and then uh she's
the only person that she knows that
might know her she's aware she's a huge
fan so she's aware of monica rambo or
the rainbow connection she finds her she
goes to talk to her and say oh she's off
world she's dealing with something and
we in either in a post-credits or
something kamala realizes whatever it is
that has captain marvel so consistently
off-world is not by her choosing oh she
actually is being held captive and needs
somebody to save her and so it's up to
kamala and monica rambo to go rescue
captain marvel from whoever's holding
it's more obvious oh it's more it's more
you know something so they drink morbius
blood
fly through space well i mean he could
swim and jump off of a giant battle or
whatever yeah tanker
i can swim and also jump off things
philip someday we'll find it the rambo
is going to rise in there okay don't
worry about it all the rambo connections
just before we uh we get closer to the
end i do want to approach some of you
guys uh your pitches for this discussion
topic um for the marvel's the marvel's
cameo we're getting miles morales
i would love that for kamala khan i
would love that for kamala khan at the
end of christmas marvel and then bring
them into the marbles uh morbius
this would be an interesting time to
bring in miles morales as a spiderman
especially when noah knows spider-man
right now and then if all of a sudden
there's two spider-man and it's a little
bit of a younger generation right it's
like with her and oh it would be cool if
they had a little bit will they won't
they i think that'd be that'd be kind of
cool uh all the young avenger vibes
someone said hey bishop all all caps
okay bishop would be perfect timing my
only issue with seeing kate bishop is
their worlds are so different right now
especially because kate bishop came from
like money money which is upstate new
york and we have uh kamala khan who's a
brown girl in new jersey so i think it's
going to take a minute for them to
actually meet but i want them to talk
because i know they get along and also
the age difference is very big they
would get along but also kate bishop
could add a little quit it
bishop could add a little bit of that
fun energy of when you do take that very
terrestrial energy of like low stakes
kind of person and put them in something
really weird just having that like voice
of reason that's calling it out they
could also have bruno make the equipment
4k bishop's arrows so no more okay
the trick arrows just like this
i'm upset i forgot about bruno my with
miles morales a little love triangle
yeah
ross butler as nova so i think nova this
is a perfect time for nova to appear
nova
shut up
how about austin butler as nova oh yeah
fresh off elvis
uh i think i'm nova baby
yeah seeing that as nova what's the
chance of us seeing whole clean
uh and secret invasion maybe and sacred
invasion or well i think when you're
talking we're going to be a touching
we're going to be touching we're going
to be touching the scrolls we're coming
to touch it
and the marvel's for sure yeah i think
we're gonna get a little bit of taste so
it's like we're gonna see some people
what's the chance what's the chance a
little huggleberry hunkleberry finn
uncle berry fan mls beats had a great
super chat will it be a problem for
monica or carol if kamala is part scroll
or cree i do think that's a way they're
gonna connect
is she she either has creep blood or
scroll blood or something's going on
there if it is creep blood or creed dna
it could be like an inhumans thing it
could be getting there but it would be
interesting if carol's there to like
kill kamala because she's related and
then monica's royalties yeah and monica
also is fun right like it's kind of like
the terminator one to terminator 2
storyline we're like in terminator 1
it's the one that's there to kill you in
terms of two there to save you if you've
invert that where she's like oh my hero
is here to kill me oh yeah wow yes that
would be very she powers up
this is just a side note nothing to do
with nerd stuff um
j cole wrote a song called nas hates me
because nas was his favorite rapper and
he was not like your music sucks
along the same level it happens charlie
charlie 836 uh donated uh for phillip
and i think this is incorrect spelling
of the name but the attention was there
oh just for me hi thank you i don't
think it was for captain phillips
i don't know kevin phillips did some
great stuff oh we gotta get some we have
breaking news guys here i'm sorry we're
breaking news on the break room uh we've
received the poll results of do you like
men
uh and in a shocking victory yes
as one with 37 percent well 31 is only
with a mustache wow tied with me no
i don't know exactly
yes and only were the last then it's a
lance
i love that those are emails it's like i
do not like men unless they have a
mustache yeah i hate man do we enter on
ron's yet you guys think happy could be
a client of jennifer walters and
she-hulk i asked because of no way home
murdoch tells happy he's going to need a
really good lawyer sound like a layup to
me we did talk about this and i don't
remember if it was on the break room or
office we did talk about it here i
cannot remember where someone was saying
that like daredevil was going to be
happy where i was like i don't think
he's going to be happy
i do love the idea that he would be
jennifer jennifer walters would be
happy's lawyer that could be fun that's
just the fun where happy thought that
matt murdock was going to be his lawyer
too yeah you know the reason why i could
see jennifer wallace who's not wanting
to be or why i don't want her to be
happy's lawyer is because i want
jennifer walters to be start starting to
work with only people that are super
powered and then she sees he's happy
coming it's like you're abusing your
power happy comes in with like a
leftover mark one glove yeah and it's
like i'm powered the power
gets really hot
i'm
carol could be like a second mom and
monica feels abandoned that's another
interesting take if carol's there and
she like loves hanging out with come on
yeah i'm like
where were you you killed my mom well i
think that's i'm so excited for the
marvels for this reason because the the
connection they all have whether it's
like in their powers but also in who
they are because it's like carol danvers
fighting alongside monica's mom and then
we have monica as a child that's like
now struggling with a not having her mom
and then we have uh kamala khan and i
want that relationship of kamala khan
and monica so bad because there are two
pocs in new york and i'm like let's let
them talk let them talk and figure out
that they have too much and similar real
quick i just want to say this is as uh
the person that makes these kind of
decisions uh you know i authorized tommy
having health care uh uh and i
authorized storm virgil your idea zach
cannot come back unless he comes back
with a sick dad stash
too bad he's fighting every machine in
los angeles and fighting all the
machines and we won't let him have any
man escape also cj russell really quick
said we need cannon terrigen missed asap
me and brandon in big question go off
about a bunch of things and the terrigen
missed is one of them we do in the next
big question i'll come out next sunday
you'll you'll hear us talking about the
territory the characters would be great
but now that okay just watch big
questions
thank you for your earlier super chat
asking for mandatory fun you know we did
it doug uh ms west 87 loving all of
jessica's mf doom comments
uh
charlie 836 also asking for our arcane 2
coverage jessica who's in that charlie
836 actually
hey charlie i got you baby i got you you
can super chat a million dollars we're
not covering that trash oh my gosh also
aj stanton 1991 thank you for going over
damage control this weekend on big
question you guys rock you know what
thank you thank you thank you thank you
for watching big question and thank you
everyone for watching the break room
well real quick before we go avril has a
great question okay uh thank you for the
super chat do you all believe that chris
chris hemsworth saying this might be his
last storm absolutely not i don't
believe that for a second because he's
got so much bigger again what else would
he go do he has so much fun another
spider head spider head he's doing
extraction two or whatever no spoilers
on spider and i'm watching it tonight
i'm not kidding i haven't watched it but
i think what is
netflix show a little sci-fi
like an island where people it's based
on a short film yeah an island people go
to and they get they sign a way to get
like tested on i think the spider head
is the name of the island journeys
smaller oh yeah and then it has miles
teller yeah okay so it's a hot castle
can you touch my finger like eating
plants
that's not how it works i'll be right
here for the cookies at a great super
chat santa in the is the first mutant in
the mcu confirmed yeah
i love that or eternal i could go either
way someone said philip is my jesus and
let me tell you i say that every day i
show up to work well i do
i just want to mention camera four real
quick i tried my hardest john i know
you're out sick today to end the show at
3 59 and everyone just said keep
extending to read more super chats yeah
i'm trying to end this show you're on
time real quick shout out to john who's
feeling under the weather yeah it's not
kovid but he's just he better not be
watching him he's got jovid i think yeah
but we do thank you all for joining us
today here on the break group what a
great monday we had we'll be back
tomorrow and every day this week
covering all that hot news you want to
talk about having mandatory fun running
polls reading super chats having a blast
thank you all for being here today thank
you we gotta turn this back into our
normal break room so people can have
their snacks again uh but we love you uh
and we'll catch you tomorrow right here
same channel same time latest gainers
have a great day
charlie
you